Showtime
what's up see you got my message that
light was perfect me what made you think
of that no I think I saw it in a comic
book somewhere you want me you're gonna
have to catch me
the youtubers is Charlie happy Batman
day so Zack cider dropped a couple more
Justice League teasers we got Batman
stuff we got flash and cyborg so let's
break it down some you are looking at
this Commissioner Gordon picture and
going like oh my god what's Batman a day
I don't understand but I'm just so happy
that they're dropping new stuff for
Justice League so the other big thing is
that we got to look at the flash in the
cyborg costumes from that crazy
alternate future timeline that Batman
hallucinate 'add in Batman V Superman so
I'll explain Commissioner Gordon Batman
days stuff first then I'll talk about
the flash and cyborg so if you didn't
know JK Simmons and a lot of the other
cast of the Tobey Maguire spider-man
movies are now going to be in the DC
extended universe as pretty big
characters Willem Dafoe is like the
other big one to Green Goblin from Tobey
Maguire spider-man is now going to be in
the Aquaman movie but JK Simmons is
going to be in all the Batman related
stuff as Commissioner Gordon so here we
see the new bat-signal which is like way
bigger than the previous one and we see
JK Simmons here who looks very much like
Frank Miller's Commissioner Gordon which
is very true to Zack Snyder style it's
very much inspired by Frank Miller's
designs
speaking of which Frank Miller and a lot
of other Batman comic book creators are
out doing signings at comic book shops
for Batman day today so you might run
into some of them if you're buying comic
books today but if you're confused about
Batman day and you have no idea why you
don't get an extra day off of school
because of it what happened is is three
years ago Batman had his 75th
anniversary so DC just started a day to
honor that and they've done it each year
since then so this is like the third
anniversary of Batman day so in like 30
years when you have children of your own
and we've seen Marvel and DC reboot
their universes like four or five more
times and they turn to you and ask what
the hell is Batman day you can say that
you were there when Batman day started
but Commissioner Gordon stuff so a lot
of people were talking about JK Simmons
earlier this year where he looked just
super jacked up just enjoying himself at
a random gym and people were like holy
crap Commissioner Gordon is going to
wreck up during these movies
because remember Justice League is
happening next JK Simmons is a big part
that but then they have the Batman solo
film he'll be a much bigger part of that
because it'll be so Batman centric but
then even funnier than that JK Simmons
came out and was just like hey you know
everybody's making all this noise about
this picture but I'm really just getting
in shape just because I want to just for
fun whether or not he was deflecting I
just think it's funny you know JK
Simmons grandpa Commissioner Gordon is
so jacked up it's definitely inspiring
because JK Simmons is like 61 years old
now so when you're 61 you could look
like that as long as you keep working
out but if you really want to see like
hardcore JK Simmons and you've already
watched the Tobey Maguire spider-man
films that's a deep cut but it's not
hardcore JK Simmons he's way more
hardcore in whiplash from 2014 that was
like a smaller movie just about this
really special music school where he's a
teacher that makes the drill instructor
from Full Metal Jacket look like a pink
fluffy Panda really I'm expecting his
Commissioner Gordon to be a little more
tempered because Batman is the guy that
goes crazy Gordon is usually written as
being a little more withdrawn but on to
the flash and cyborg so they revealed
these costumes that were to use during
Batman V Superman and even if you paused
the scene where Batman has that vision
of him to find Lois she's the key you
still don't get a really good look at
the costume but this is what it looks
like just sitting in storage totally
does not resemble a flash costume so I
think they were right and not hyping
this up and you have to imagine that
this is from a post-apocalyptic timeline
where they don't assemble the Justice
League like fine Lois she's the key
bring everyone together or else this
will happen this version of the flash
costume looks much more inspired by
Bruce Wayne's Dark Knight Returns battle
suit that he wore during Batman vs
Superman the cyborg costume looks a
little more true to the comics right
after he fuses with the mother box beat
you know becomes a cyborg character in
the technology kind of overwhelms his
mind he turns into this drone character
you know he's kind of on autopilot just
going crazy it takes him a little while
to reassert his conscious mind so that
he can control himself so they haven't
said too much about cyborg in the movie
but there are reports that they're like
slowly pulling back on him just a little
bit to like
thread him out in future movies more
like they don't want to get too bogged
down explaining a bunch of different
things in Justice League they want to
get to the fun stuff like Superman
coming back the Justice League actually
forming a little bit faster so we'll see
more cyborg in the future films so like
spider-man very important in civil war
but a small part of it I think one of
the primary concerns of DC right now in
addition to nailing justice Lee is
getting Superman back to that place
where he needs to be because they're
doing a Man of Steel sequel Henry Cavill
agent has already come out and said oh
yeah we're definitely developing it but
Superman is a character right now just
not quite as popular as some of the
other comic book characters like Batman
or some of the Marvel characters so I
think they're gonna pay special
attention to the way Superman is
portrayed in the next couple of DC films
to get him back to that place where
everyone's like holy crap we need
another Superman film right now but let
me know in the comments what do you guys
think about JK Simmons Commissioner
Gordon and what do you think about these
post-apocalyptic flash cyborg costumes I
know they're going with a more tech
based flash costume but I think there's
still a little bit of tuning left to be
done like I'm expecting the final
version of the flash costume to look a
little bit different when we get to the
movie but happy Batman day so in that
same vein there is a new round of the
flash blu-ray giveaway all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber leave a
comment on this video there'll be more
DC to announce the winner of the next
time I post a DC video and if you didn't
notice YouTube rolled out a couple new
features if you're on your phone or
you're on like a tablet you can actually
click on the links now that I put at the
end of video so like when I point to
stuff when you're on mobile you can
actually click on those but there might
be a few bugs I don't know if they've
rolled it out for a Windows Phone yet so
it should be posting some new Marvel
later tonight but if you guys have any
special requests just leave them in the
comments if you're wondering what all
this looks a little different I got a
new camera that I'm still figuring out
but while you guys wait for my next
video to post you can click here for
more Batman Justice League and you can
click here to learn all about killer
frost on the flash this season thank you
so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight